لقد كان موسمًا انتخابيًا متوترًا
ولم ينته بعد
مع سحق بطاقات الاقتراع عبر البريد التي يتعين
عدها ، فقد اقترب موعد الاستدعاء في
العديد من الولايات ،
ولكن بينما يستمر التصويت المشروع في المقاطعة ، أعلن
الرئيس دونالد ترامب
فوزه
بشكل خاطئ ويتهم
الديمقراطيين بالمحاولة.  لسرقة الانتخابات ،
هذا تزوير
على الجمهور الأمريكي ، هذا أمر
محرج لبلدنا كنا مستعدين
للفوز في هذه الانتخابات
بصراحة لقد فزنا بهذه الانتخابات
دون أي دليل يوحي
بأن عد جميع الأصوات من شأنه أن
يحرم ناخبيه من حق التصويت
ويهدد باتخاذ إجراءات قانونية  لإيقاف
العد الشرعي للأصوات
، انتقدت حملة نائب الرئيس السابق جو بايدن
تصريحات الرئيس ووصفها بأنها
شائنة
غير مسبوقة وغير صحيحة تحدث بايدن أيضًا في
ساعات الصباح الباكر يوم الأربعاء يطلب من
الأمريكيين
التحلي بالصبر ، فهذا ليس مكاني أو
مكان دونالد ترامب لإعلان
من فاز في هذه الانتخابات.
قرار الشعب الأمريكي
الرقم القياسي للبريد الإلكتروني  تؤخر أوراق الاقتراع هذا العام النتائج ، الأمر الذي توقعته بسبب جائحة covet 19 ، سيستغرق الأمر وقتًا لجدولة كل صوت بطريقة منهجية وآمنة